robots are taking over sidewalk to
deliver food in some cities the wheel
machines come in all shapes and sizes
companies behind the technologists say
the robots lower the cost of delivery
and boost local businesses my Mary are
very Elle shows us how not everyone
welcomes the technology from your
favorite restaurant to your front door
it smells so good
this high-tech robot could one day
replace your delivery guy with these
robots we can actually provide these
services to people give them actual
affordable access to the goods that they
want to need it to do that these marble
robots travel on San Francisco sidewalks
but now one lawmaker wants to hit the
brakes
banning robots altogether because of
safety concerns and a lack of
regulations then you start asking
questions like what is this like five of
them ten of them coming down the street
let's make sure that the sidewalks are
safe for people the city already blocks
bikes and skateboards on sidewalks Alice
Chu and Pyrrha work for an organization
that advocates for seniors and the
disabled they worry these delivery BOTS
will create more problems we don't have
enough room as it is and why make it
more complex I'm thinking oh my god what
am I going to do when I encounter one of
them we're teaching a robot that were
lots learning and we're learning from
the people around us
Harrison XI his marbles had a product in
operations he says their robots use
technology similar to self-driving cars
relying on at least four cameras and
advanced sensors to perceive the world
around them so it has 16 scans that it's
doing this specific model and it's
collecting millions of data points a
second and so it can tell the distance
to everything around it the robots are
constantly mapping city sidewalks to
optimize their routes and for now take a
human chaperone along on their trips
robot delivery companies are popping up
around the country from Arkansas to
Washington DC several other states
including Idaho and Virginia have passed
laws welcoming the technology Wisconsin
is considering similar legislation but
the fight over their future could come
down to the local level one of the
things that I think we value in Sarah
Cisco is really people over robots over
robots as weird as it sounds I don't
want to picture myself as anti-roma it's
just that I am Pro people on sidewalks
for CBS this morning midday ovule San
Francisco I think we're all pro people
on sidewalks all right we are all pro
people I mean I think the robots are
gonna stop but it is a little awkward
right now looking like a refrigerator
yeah go ahead
walking down that sidewalk right yeah
five or ten at a time could be developed
and are you supposed to tip the robot no
the army over